welcome to the very first episode of
Genius eats I've shot this a million
times because the lighting keeps
changing cuz the clouds keep moving God
damn it the sun today we are going to
talk about one of my favorite spots for
a bun me now my personal favorite spot
is Saigon Bakery this right here is one
of the best bun mes that you can get in
Los Angeles now if you notice the shape
of their bunm is a little bit different
now they do have the typical one that's
a longer baguette but this the one that
I get I love it it's nice and wide and
thick like Shack's
dick and of course you can never forget
the classic every bunme spot has the
special you know when chefs talk about
what makes a complete dish they usually
talk about four things right salt acid
fat and heat and this has all of that in
this nice delicious baguette so for all
my bunme lovers out there what's your
favorite spot in Los Angeles leave it in
the comments below see yall next time